to me personally i think it's clear that
if agi were to be achieved that would
change the course of human history
agi wise i was
you know i was making this decision
about what do i want to focus on after
vr and i'm still working on vr
regularly i spend a day a week kind of
consulting with meta and i you know baz
styles me the consulting cto it's kind
of like the sherlock holmes that comes
in and consults on some of the specific
tough issues and i'm still pretty
passionate about all of that but i have
been
figuring out how to compartmentalize and
force that into a smaller box to work on
some other things and i did come down to
this decision between working on uh
economical nuclear fission or artificial
general intelligence
and uh the fission side of things i've
i've got a bunch of interesting things
going that way but
it would take that would be a fairly big
project thing to do i don't think it
needs to be as big as people expect i do
think something original spacex sized
um you build it power your building off
of it and then the government i think
will come around to what you need to is
everybody loves an existence proof i
think it's possible somebody should be
doing this but it's going to involve
some politics it's going to involve
decent sized teams and a bunch of this
cross-functional stuff that i don't love
while
the artificial general intelligence side
of things
um
it seems to me like this is
the highest leverage moment for
potentially a single individual
potentially in the history of the world
where
the things that we know about the brain
about what we can do with artificial
intelligence uh nobody can say
absolutely on any of these things but
i am not a madman
for saying that it is likely that the
code for artificial general intelligence
is going to be
tens of thousands of lines of code not
millions of lines of code this is code
that conceivably one individual could
write unlike writing a new web browser
or operating system
and based on the progress that ai has
machine learning has made in the recent
decade
it's likely that the important things
that we don't know
are relatively simple there's probably a
handful of things and my bet is that
i think there's
less than six key insights that need to
be made each one of them can probably be
written on the back of an envelope we
don't know what they are but when
they're put together in concert with
gpus at scale and the data that we all
have access to that we can make
something that behaves like
a human being or like a living creature
and that can then be educated in
whatever ways that we need to get to the
point where we can have universal remote
workers where anything that somebody
does mediated by a computer and doesn't
require physical interaction
um that an agi will be able to do we can
already simulate the you know the
equivalent of the zoom the zoom meetings
with avatars and uh synthetic deep fakes
and whatnot we can definitely do that uh
we have superhuman capabilities on any
narrow thing that we can that we can
formalize and make a loss function for
but there's things we don't know how to
do now
but i don't think they are
unapproachably hard now that's
incredibly hubristic to say that it's
like but i think that what i said a
couple years ago is a 50 chance that
somewhere there will be signs of life of
agi in 2030 and i've probably increased
that slightly i may be at 55 60 percent
now because i do think there's a little
sense of acceleration there
so i wonder what the and by the way you
also written that i i bet with hindsight
we will find that clear antecedents of
all the critical remaining steps for agi
are already buried somewhere in the vast
literature of today so the ideas are
already there
i think that's likely the case one of
the things that appeals to so many
people including me about the promise of
agi is we know that we're only drinking
from a straw from the the fire hose of
all the information out there i mean you
look at just in a very narrowly bounded
field like machine learning like you
can't read all the papers that that come
out all the time you can't go back and
read all the clever things that people
did in the 90s or earlier that people
had forgotten about because they didn't
pan out at the time when they were
trying to do them with 12 neurons
um
so that this idea that yeah i think
there are gems buried in some of the
older literature that was not the path
taken by everything and you can see a
kind of herd mentality on the things
that happen right now it's almost funny
to see like oh google does something and
open ai does something meta does
something and you know they're the same
people that all talk to each other and
they're all one-upping each other and
they're all capable of implementing each
other's work given a month or two after
somebody has an announcement of that
but there's a there's a whole world of
possible approaches to machine learning
and i think that we probably will in
hindsight go back and see it's like yeah
that was kind of clearly predicted by
this early paper here i you know and
this turns out that if you do this and
this and take this result from
from animal training and this thing from
neuroscience over here and put it
together and set up this curriculum for
them to learn in that that's kind of
what it took
you don't have too many people now that
are still saying it's not possible or
it's going to take hundreds of years
and 10 years ago you would get you would
collect get a collection of experts and
you would have a decent chunk on the
margin that either say not possible or
a couple hundred years might be
centuries and the median estimate would
be like 50 70 years and it's been coming
down and i know with me saying eight
years for something that still puts me
on the optimistic side but it's not
crazy out in the fringes and just being
able to look at that at a meta level
about the trend of the the uh the trend
of the predictions going down there
the idea that something could be
happening relatively soon
now
i do not believe in fast takeoffs you
know that's one of the safety issues
that people say it's like oh it's going
to go foom and the ai is going to take
over the world there's a lot of reasons
i don't think that's a credible position
and i think that we will go from a point
where we start seeing things that that
credibly look like uh look like animals
behaviors and i have a human voice box
wired into them uh it's like i tried to
get elon uh to say it's like your your
pig neurolink give it a human voice box
and let it start uh learning human words
i i think that you know i think animal
intelligence is closer to human
intelligence than a lot of people like
to think and i think that culture and
modalities of io are i make the gulf
seem a lot bigger than it actually is
there's just that smooth spectrum of how
the brain developed and cortexes and
scaling of different things going on
there cultural modalities of io yes
language is
um
the sort of loss in translation conceals
a lot of intelligence and ah so you're
when you think about signs of life for
agi you're thinking about
human interpretable signs so the example
i give if we get to the point where
you've got a learning disabled toddler
some some kind of real special needs uh
child that can still
interact with their favorite tv show and
video game and can be trained and
learned in some appreciably human-like
way at that point you can deploy an army
of engineers cognitive scientists
education developmental developmental
education people and you've got so many
advantages there unlike real education
where you can do rollbacks and a b
testing and you can find a golden path
through a curriculum of different things
if you get to that point learning
disabled toddler i think that it's uh
it's going to be a done deal
but you think we'll we'll know when we
see it so uh there's there's been a lot
of really interesting general learning
progress from deep mind
open the eye a little bit too
i tend to
believe that tesla autopilot deserves a
lot more credit than is getting
for
making progress on the general yeah on
sort of on the doing the multitask
learning thing and increasing the number
of tasks and automating that
uh process of
uh sort of uh learning from the edge
discovering the edge cases and learning
from the edge cases that is
it's really approaching from a different
angle the general learning problem of
agi but the more clear approach comes
from deep mind where you have these kind
of game situations and you
build systems
there but i i don't know
um people seem to be quite
um
yeah there will always be people that
just won't believe it and i
fundamentally don't care i mean i don't
care if they don't believe it i you know
when it starts doing people's jobs and i
mean like i don't care about the
philosophical zombie argument absolutely
absolutely but will you do you think you
will notice that something special has
happened here and or
um because to me i've been noticing a
lot of special things i think
a lot of credits should go to deep bind
for alpha zero
uh that was truly special so self-play
mechanisms achieve
sort of solve problems that used to be
thought unsolvable like the game of go
also i mean protein folding starting to
get into that space where learning is
doing
at first there's not it wasn't
end-to-end learning and so now it's
end-to-end learning
of the of a very difficult previously
thought unsolvable problem of protein
folding
and so um
yeah
do where where do you think would be a
really magical moment for you
uh there have been incredible things
happening in recent years like you say
all of the the things from deepmind and
openai that have been
huge showpiece things but when you
really get down to it you read the
papers and you look at the way the
models are going you know it's it's
still like a feed forward you push
something in something comes out i on
the end i mean maybe there's diffusion
models or monte carlo tree rollouts and
different things going on but it's not a
being it's not close to a being i am
that's that's going through a you know a
lifelong learning process do you want
something that kind of gives signs of a
being like what's the difference
between
a neural network
a feed forward neural network and a
being
what's up where's the fundamentally the
brain is a recurrent neural network
generating an action policy i mean it's
implemented on a biological substrate
and it's interesting thinking about
things like that where we know
fundamentally the brain is not a
convolutional neural network or a
transformer uh those are specialized
things that that are very valuable for
what we're doing but it's not the way
the brain is doing now i do think
consciousness and ai in general is a
substrate independent mechanism where it
doesn't have to be implemented the way
the brain is but if you've only got one
existence proof there's certainly some
value in caring about what it says and
does
i am
and so the the idea that anything that
can be done with a narrow ai that you
can quantify up a loss function for a
reward mechanism you're almost certainly
going to be able to produce something
that's more resource effective to train
and deploy and use in an inference mode
you know train a whole lot using an
inference but uh a living being is going
to be something that's a continuous
lifelong learned task agnostic thing and
learning is really important too and the
long-term memory
so memories
is a big
part of that
we've got
you know again i have all the respect in
the world for the amazing things that
are being done now but sometimes they
can be taken a little bit out of context
with things like
like there's some smoke and mirrors
going on like the gotto the recent work
the multitask learning stuff you know
it's amazing that it's the one it's one
model that plays all the atari games i
am as well as doing all these other
things but i of course it didn't learn
to do all of those it was instructed in
doing that by other reinforcement
learners going through and doing that
and even in the case of all the games
it's still going with a specific
hand-coded reward function in each of
those atari games where it's not that
you know how does it it just wants to
spend its summer afternoon playing atari
because that's the most interesting
thing for it so it's again not a general
it's not learning the way humans learn
and there's i believe a lot of things
that are challenging to make a loss
function for that you can train uh
through these existing conventional
things we're gonna chip away at all the
things that people do um
that we can turn into narrow
ai problems and billions of probably
trillions of dollars of value are going
to be created by that but there's still
going to be a set of things and we've
got questionable cases like the
self-driving car where it's possible
it's not my bet but it's it's plausible
that the long tail could be problematic
enough that that really does require a
full-on artificial general intelligence
i the counter argument is that data
solves almost every everything is an
interpolation problem if you have enough
data and tesla may be able to get enough
data
from all of their deployed stuff to be
able to work like that but maybe not and
there are all the other problems about
like say you want to have a strategy
meeting and you want to go ahead and
bring in all of your remote workers and
your consultants and you want a world
where some of those could be ais that
are you know that are talking and
interacting with you in a an area that
is too murky to have a crisp loss
function
but they still have things that on some
level they're they're rewarded on some
internal level for building a valuable
to humans uh kind of life and ability to
interact with things
see i i still think that uh self-driving
cars solving that problem will take us
very far towards agi you might not need
agi
but i am really inspired by what
autopilot is doing uh waymo
so these some of the other companies i
think waymo leads the way there
is also really interesting but they
don't have quite as ambitious of an
effort in terms of learning based
sort of
data-hungry approach to driving which i
think is very close to the kind of thing
that would take us far
towards agi yeah and it's a it's a funny
thing because as far as i can tell elon
is completely serious about all of his
concerns about agi you know being an
existential threat and you know i tried
to draw him out to talk about ai and he
just didn't want to and i think that
you know i get that little fatalistic
sense from him and it's weird because
his company could very well be the
leading company leading towards a lot of
that where uh tesla being a super
pragmatic company uh that's doing things
because they really want to solve this
actual problem it's a different vibe
than the research oriented companies
where it's a great time to be an ai
researcher you've got your pick of
trillion dollar companies that will you
know that will pay you to kind of work
on the problems you're interested in but
that's not necessarily driving hard
towards the the core problem of agi as
something that's going to produce a lot
of value by doing things that you know
that people currently do or would like
to do
you